-"Le monde dont je rêve
"serait un monde
"où les humains sont tous égaux,
"où le réchauffement climatique
serait enrayé
"et même inversé.
"Un monde où les humains
seraient capables
"de produire la sphère de Dyson.
"C'est une méga-structure
hypothétique
"qui permet, en entourant le soleil
sans cacher la lumière,
"de produire une énergie illimitée
sans polluer.
"Pour de tels projets,
"tous les pays doivent être unis,
donc, pas de guerre.
"Des personnes comme Poutine
nous en empêchent."
Le vélo dérape.
-"Mon monde idéal serait un monde
où tous les humains seraient égaux.
"Il n'y aurait
pas de discriminations,
"de racisme, de sexisme,
ou d'homophobie.
"Ils seront tous libres
de leurs actes,
"sans personne pour les juger,
sur leur façon de penser, d'agir,
"ou leur physique.
Durant leur scolarité,
"de 6 à 18 ans,
ils apprendront les bases : lire,
"écrire, compter, et découvriront
des métiers en primaire,
"et ils se formeront au métier
qu'ils auront choisi
"dès le collège.
Ce serait un monde sans pollution,
"donc sans réchauffement climatique.
Les plantes, les animaux
"et la biodiversité
seraient très abondants."
-"Le monde parfait où je voudrais
vivre est le nôtre,
"avec moins de défauts,
comme la pollution
"et les différentes discriminations.
Sinon,
"je voudrais m'amuser
sans me demander
"quel métier choisir."
J'ai tué personne,
je précise.
"Bref, voilà le monde
dans lequel je voudrais vivre."
"- Mon monde utopique
serait un monde
"sans guerre, sans dictateurs,
sans épidémies.
"Un monde
qui ne serait pas recouvert
"de villes et d'immeubles,
où le vert et le bleu
"remplaceraient
le gris triste et sale.
"Il y aurait des petites maisons
"avec des jardins,
il y aurait de grandes forêts
"et des lacs, des mers
et des océans propres,
"la faune et la flore auraient
encore toute leur place.
"Il n'y aurait pas d'espèces
qui disparaîtraient.
"L'habitat et la nourriture
seraient disponibles pour tous."
Musique électronique douce
"-J'aimerais vivre dans un monde
"où on peut assumer nos différences,
sans devoir
"ressembler à tout le monde
pour être accepté dans la société.
"Un monde
où la gentillesse est banalisée.
"sans hiérarchie,
"sans personnes qu'on doit
plus respecter que d'autres.
"Un monde où la moquerie
n'est pas une chose
"drôle à faire.
"Un monde où on respecte
la planète, les autres,
"et surtout soi-même."
...
Musique douce au piano
-Lilou, Riwan,
Mohamed, Coline, Maël.
Ils sont nés en 2008.
Ils vivent à Rennes
et sont dans le même collège.
Nous les suivons dans leur vie
sur 10 ans
depuis leur année de 6e
avec une idée en tête :
quel avenir les attend ?
Qui seront-ils en 2030 ?
Les réponses se dessinent
avec le temps,
dans ce documentaire impossible
à écrire à l'avance.
Voici quelques moments de vie
capturés dans l'année,
celle de leurs 13 ans.
Musique intense
...
Cette année,
nos cinq jeunes comptent
parmi les grands du collège.
Ils sont en 4e.
-Je vais vous rendre vos tests,
et on va les corriger ensemble.
-Ils sont encore tous
en option latin.
-Mohamed, c'est très bien.
Lilou,
beaucoup de connaissances.
Maël...
Coline...
Riwan, excellent.
-4 sur 4 pour Riwan,
la note maximale.
-L'orthographe,
ce serait bien
d'y prendre garde.
"-Les noms propres, prénoms,
ont des majuscules,
"les connaissances,
c'est bien."
-Là est le dieu
protecteur du foyer.
Le serpent
que vous trouvez en bas du laraire,
l'autel domestique,
représente le génie
du père de famille, l'ancêtre.
Je vous rappelle
que les hommes
sont prédominants et les femmes
comptent pour du beurre.
Quel est le nom
du dieu des enfers ?
Oui, Maël ?
-Hadès.
-Et non pas ?
-Arès.
-Voilà.
Quelles déesses s'opposent
à la mission d'Enée ? Riwan ?
-Junon et Athéna ?
-Très bien,
et parce qu'elles n'ont pas
été choisies, qui a été choisi ?
-Aphrodite.
-Que promet chacune d'elle
à Pâris ?
Mohamed, allez-y.
-Héra lui promet
le plus beau des royaumes.
-Oui.
-Athéna lui promet
de le rendre invincible au combat
et Aphrodite lui promet la main
de la plus belle femme du monde.
-Excellent,
je vous félicite.
Je vous retrouve mardi.
Musique douce
...
-En cours de techno,
Lilou, Riwan et Mohamed
voient l'envers du décor.
-Installez-vous vite.
Vous allez attaquer directement
le travail
sur le labyrinthe.
-Ils passent de joueurs
à créateurs de jeux vidéo.
-Vous écrivez l'histoire du jeu,
avec écran d'accueil,
règles du jeu,
maniement du jeu.
D'accord ?
-Ca va, c'est facile.
-Si tu le dis.
-En gros, c'est un labyrinthe,
si tu touches les traits
une fois,
tu retournes au début,
si tu récupères l'objet,
tu gagnes le truc,
c'est écrit "gagné"
et tu passes au niveau suivant.
-On imagine que forcément,
on a un personnage, qui se déplace,
on va dire que c'est ça.
Il arrive,
il se retire, le jeu peut commencer.
-Ouais.
-Premier écran,
l'écran d'accueil,
et puis vous allez choisir
un nom pour le jeu.
-"Indiana Jones".
-Non.
-Hmm... "L'aventurier" ?
"Le labyrinthe" ?
-"Le labyrinthe impossible".
-Ouais, je sais pas,
"Mission impossible" ?
"Le chemin de l'enfer" ?
-"L'aventurier de l'extrême".
-Le prof de techno
est aussi le prof principal.
-On va prendre un petit temps,
vos délégués ont besoin
de faire une synthèse...
-A tout moment, il peut lancer
un échange sur la vie de classe.
-Que pensez-vous
de l'ambiance de classe,
en général ?
Qu'est-ce qui dérange ?
-Ouais, elle est pas hyper bien,
genre... Je sais pas...
J'aime pas trop l'ambiance,
je pense pas...
-Il faudrait développer,
pour que vos camarades
puissent répondre.
Quelle est la critique ?
Qu'est-ce qui fait
que l'ambiance est pas top ?
-Ben ça dépend des personnes,
et surtout, ça dépend...
De...
Je sais pas trop
comment développer ça...
C'est un peu compliqué
d'en parler maintenant...
-Ca dépend des personnes.
-Voilà, mais ça reste compliqué.
-OK.
Je vous souhaite
une bonne journée !
Lilou ?
-Oui ?
-On va prendre
cinq petites minutes.
Assieds-toi,
je t'en prie.
Donc moi,
je viens juste d'apprendre ça.
-Alors, oui...
C'est particulièrement en sport
et en arts plastiques.
-Ouais ?
-Oui, en fait,
des fois,
elles se moquent de moi...
-Ouais ?
-...en cours.
-Et c'est
des moqueries personnelles ?
-Oui,
des moqueries soit sur le physique,
soit sur...
Juste elles rigolent en parlant
de mon style vestimentaire, etc.
-D'accord, ah, oui.
-Et il y a des personnes
qui créent des rumeurs,
ou soit elles rigolent
en me regardant mal, etc.
Donc c'est pas hyper sympathique.
-C'est souvent ?
Ca dure depuis un moment ?
-Depuis le début de l'année...
-Waouh...
-Oui.
-Faut pas hésiter, tu sais, Lilou,
à venir m'en parler, à moi,
ou à quelqu'un d'autre.
Donc... OK.
Tu veux que je les rencontre,
ces jeunes filles ?
-Ben, je pense pas,
je pense que...
Pour le...
-On peut pas laisser continuer ça
comme ça.
-Euh, oui, mais...
-Je vois bien,
je vois dans tes yeux, là,
c'est...
C'est pas une situation
que tu...
-Oui, mais j'ai pas envie
de leur créer de problèmes, sinon...
Il rit doucement.
-Elles te créent des problèmes,
d'accord ?
Donc c'est pas une histoire
de leur créer de problèmes.
Tu dois venir au collège
en étant sereine,
et pas en craignant
de te faire moquer
par tes camarades.
Donc il faut remettre ça en place
absolument.
Je vais les rencontrer quand même,
je pense.
-Oui, d'accord,
mais moi, je...
Je sais pas trop.
-Tu veux que ça reste comme ça ?
-Non, mais...
-Donc faut qu'on trouve
une petite solution.
Tout le monde doit être bien.
Donc y a pas de raison.
Donc je vais les rencontrer, OK ?
-OK.
-Allez, bonne journée !
-Bonne journée.
Tonalité de téléphone
...
*-Oui, bonjour ?
-Bonjour,
je tenais à vous appeler
parce que j'ai eu
une petite discussion
avec Lilou aujourd'hui.
Il y a quelques camarades
qui se moqueraient un peu d'elle
de temps en temps.
-Je l'ai vraiment vue atteinte,
tout à l'heure.
Elle a eu très vite
les larmes aux yeux.
-Vous avez utilisé le bon mot,
on est proches du harcèlement.
-Vu son état émotionnel,
il faut que ça cesse immédiatement.
-Voilà, ma demande,
c'était que vous puissiez
en parler un peu
avec elle.
Musique troublante
...
Musique douce à la guitare
-Faut expérimenter
encore un peu.
...
-Cette année,
Maël s'est sérieusement mis
aux échecs.
Il s'est même inscrit
dans un club.
-J'ai toujours joué,
depuis que j'étais petit,
mais je me suis vraiment investi
là-dedans depuis cette année.
Ca fait réfléchir.
Plein de trucs
à apprendre,
à faire.
Tout un petit monde
sur un échiquier.
Musique au piano
-Sinon, Maël dévore toujours
des romans, et des gros.
Il lit même des pièces de théâtre,
et dans ça, il trouve le temps
de continuer le piano.
En plus, il s'intéresse
à l'élection présidentielle 2022.
D'ailleurs, une proposition
de réforme l'interpelle.
-Apparemment, ils veulent
que tout prof doit être remplacé
par un de ses collègues
s'il est absent.
Si t'as pas de cours, hop,
tu vas remplacer un autre.
On a déjà pas assez de travail
comme ça.
-Tes parents sont profs,
tu les vois travailler.
-Oui, moi, je vois ce que c'est,
comme charge de travail.
Apparemment,
y a pas mal de candidats
qui n'ont pas très bien compris ça.
...
-Si Maël entend parler
politique à la maison,
chacun s'informe
à sa façon.
Les journaux télévisés,
la radio,
ou les réseaux sociaux.
*-Faut-il revenir
sur la réforme du bac ?
*-Oui.
*-La police a trop de pouvoir ?
*-La France doit-elle rester
dans l'OTAN ?
-Faisons un point
sur ce qu'ils savent
de l'élection présidentielle.
Jingle
-Vous me demandez
pour qui je vote ?
-Je connais à peu près
tous les candidats.
-La gauche
est complètement disloquée.
-La politique,
c'est pas un truc qui m'intéresse.
-Il y a beaucoup de candidats.
-Emmanuel Macron, lui,
c'est droite, non ?
J'ai pas envie
de me tromper.
-Centre, non ?
-Un peu sur la droite.
-De droite,
quand même.
Pas non plus
extrême.
-C'est droite.
Non ? C'est gauche ? Les deux ?
-Centre ?
-C'est bien le centre.
-Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
c'est à gauche.
-Lui,
il est partout.
-Gauche ?
-Gauche, oui.
-Valérie...
-Pécresse !
-Gauche ?
-Droite,
je crois.
-Droite.
-Eric Zemmour,
droite.
-Droite, droite.
-Droite
ou extrême droite.
-Extrême droite ?
-Marine Le Pen...
-A droite.
-Droite.
-Extrême droite.
-Qui d'autre, encore...
-Y a pas la maire de Paris ?
-Euh...
-Ca me vient pas, là.
-Anne Hidalgo !
-De gauche,
il me semble.
-Plutôt gauche,
je crois.
-Yannick Jadot,
qui est écologique.
-La gauche.
Les Verts.
-Qui d'autre ?
Qui d'autre ?
-J'ai plus trop de noms
en tête.
-Y a Poutou.
-De droite, je pense.
-Je dirais gauche.
Mais je connais pas !
-Et y a un mec
qui s'appelle Rousseau, non ?
Roussel ou... C'est ça ?
-Ah non, ça me dit rien,
par contre.
-De gauche, non ?
-Il est communiste.
C'est gauche
ou droite ?
-Euh... droite.
-C'est droite.
C'est gauche !
Gauche !
-Gauche.
Gauche.
-Nathalie Arthaud ?
-Elle,
j'ai pas entendu parler.
-Je connais pas.
-Je dirais droite !
-Dupont-Aignan...
-Il a un nom
qui fait penser à gauche.
-Gauche, non ?
-Il est de droite.
-Il en reste un.
Il est berger.
-Euh...
-Jean Lassalle.
-Voilà. Je cherchais son nom.
Elle rit.
-Personne parle de lui !
-De gauche.
Non ?
Brouhaha
-Allez, on monte.
-Dans la vie,
il y a un avant
et un après la 4e.
Notamment parce que c'est l'année
où sont abordés les sujets
un peu plus pour adultes.
-Donc, nous, aujourd'hui,
on va travailler
sur la "vie sexuelle et affective".
Je vous présente
le 1er jeu :
le Pili Pili. Je sais pas
si vous savez ce que c'est,
mais c'est quelque chose
d'un peu pimenté.
Si vous n'avez pas envie de répondre
car vous êtes gênés, vous pouvez
ne pas la faire. D'accord ?
Une main innocente ?
Joan ? Ferme les yeux.
-Et je la sens.
-Encore une rouge.
-Oh !
-Elle est bien pimentée,
celle-là.
"La moyenne de la taille
du sexe d'un homme, en érection,
"en France, est :
"entre 18 et 20 cm ?"
Rires
Donc, c'est la réponse A.
La B :
entre 12 et 13 cm ?
La C : entre 15 et 16 cm ?
La D : autre réponse.
Tu hésites ?
C'est très, très disparate,
dans la classe.
Alors,
même si les statistiques,
c'est un peu... toujours ici,
on est plutôt
entre 15 et 16 cm.
Donc, la moyenne,
c'est la C.
Vous êtes plusieurs
à l'avoir surestimée, ici.
Vous êtes passés à 18-20 cm.
Si on n'est pas dans la moyenne,
on n'est pas anormal :
il peut y avoir plus petit
et il peut y avoir plus grand.
Ca reste une moyenne.
On estime que,
à cause de la pornographie,
on se retrouve
avec des idées reçues sur,
par exemple, la taille du sexe,
les relations sexuelles,
les actes sexuels, etc.,
qui sont faussées,
par la vision
de ce qui n'est
que du cinéma.
Une autre carte.
"La jalousie,
c'est bon pour le couple ?"
Point d'interrogation.
Est-ce que la jalousie a sa place
dans une relation,
qu'elle soit amicale
ou amoureuse ?
J'en vois beaucoup
qui hochent la tête.
Oui, Tania ?
-Pour moi, la jalousie,
ça montre qu'on aime la personne,
mais...
De toute façon, on ne contrôle pas
nos sentiments, nos émotions...
C'est pas notre faute,
c'est normal d'être jaloux.
-C'est obligatoire ?
-Non, pas forcément.
-Il y en a qui ne sont
pas d'accord avec toi.
Lucille ?
-Si on aime quelqu'un,
déjà, on veut son bonheur.
-D'accord.
-Donc... Enfin...
Si, genre, je sors
avec quelqu'un,
et qu'il a plein d'amies filles,
c'est sa vie, je lui fais confiance.
-Mais à partir du moment
où tu touches son téléphone,
il bégaye, c'est bizarre.
-D'accord.
-Je trouve qu'être jaloux,
c'est un peu, genre,
contrôler sa vie,
genre, dire : "Non, tu fais pas ci,
tu fais pas ça."
Ca se fait pas de faire ça.
-C'est contrôler
la vie de quelqu'un.
-C'est possessif.
-Vous avez l'air
quand même un peu mitigés.
Un peu sceptiques.
Maël ?
-Quand on aime une personne,
on lui fait confiance.
Alors que là,
si on met oui, c'est vrai que,
si on est jaloux,
ça veut dire
qu'on aime vraiment la personne,
mais c'est
un peu bizarre,
parce qu'on lui fait pas confiance.
-Pas confiance ?
-C'est important.
-Maîtriser ses émotions,
ça se travaille.
Donc, ça peut faire mal, ça peut
être difficile, mais ça doit aussi
être un travail sur soi.
Bon.
C'était intéressant ?
-Ludique.
-Ludique. Ca, c'est intéressant.
Par le jeu, ça permet
de libérer la parole et d'apprendre.
Je vous libère.
Brouhaha et cris
-Libérer la parole peut-être,
mais les verrous des garçons
n'ont pas complètement sauté.
-On n'est pas habitués à en parler.
-C'est pas le genre de truc
dont tu parles à un repas de Noël.
-Un peu gênant.
Rire gêné
-Certes.
-Logique.
-Et pourquoi
on n'en parle pas ?
-Ben, c'est un peu
de la vie privée.
-C'est gênant.
Chant des oiseaux
-Quoi ?
-C'est gênant, oui.
Il rit.
-Vous pensez pas
qu'il faudrait ?
-Ben... A un moment,
oui, sans doute, mais...
Pour l'instant,
ça m'est jamais arrivé.
-Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
-BONJOUR.
-Comment allez-vous ?
-Très bien.
-Nos collectifs d'assos,
qui travaillent
sur l'égalité
filles-garçons.
Euh... Donc,
je vous invite
à vous positionner
de ce côté-là
de la pièce.
En ligne.
On va vous donner
des cartes de personnages.
Il y a quelques traits de caractère
dessus.
A partir du moment
où vous avez la carte,
vous êtes ce personnage.
Dans le jeu,
vous allez
essayer d'imaginer
que vous êtes
cette personne-là.
Si vous pensez pouvoir répondre oui,
faites un pas en avant.
Les phrases qu'on va vous donner ont
toutes un lien avec le consentement
ou avec la relation
aux autres.
-Alors, première affirmation :
"J'ai beaucoup d'amis."
Si vous pensez
que le personnage que vous incarnez
a beaucoup d'amis,
vous avancez d'un pas.
"Je suis actif
sur les réseaux sociaux."
"Je n'ai jamais été
"l'objet de rumeurs."
-Début 6e,
je me suis rendu compte
que beaucoup de filles
lançaient beaucoup de rumeurs.
Mais à quoi ça sert ?
Elles ont qu'à regarder
"Les anges de la téléréalité"
et se taire, pas faire la même chose
dans la vraie vie !
-"Je n'ai jamais eu peur
"de venir, le matin,
au collège."
-Ca pouvait vraiment blesser.
C'est le problème.
C'est pas...
C'est amusant que pour elles,
en fait.
-"Je n'ai jamais été gêné,
dans les vestiaires."
"Je n'ai jamais subi
de moqueries."
"Je ne me suis jamais moqué
de personnes
"pour faire comme les autres."
"On a toujours respecté
mes décisions, mes choix."
-Merci. Restez sur place
et regardez
où vous êtes
les uns et les autres.
-Observez-vous
un peu, oui.
-Des phrases
vous ont un peu surpris ?
Où vous vous êtes dit :
"Qu'est-ce que ça fait là ?"
-Par exemple : "Je n'ai jamais
subi de moqueries."
Il y en a qui ont avancé,
alors que, de toute manière,
presque tout le monde
subit des moqueries,
et ce n'est pas forcément
à cause de certains critères...
C'est mon point de vue,
mais je me suis dit :
"Tout le monde en subit,
donc..."
-OK. Tu avais avancé ?
-Non.
-Je suis d'accord :
on en a tous subi.
-Oui ?
-Peu importe le...
-Quelqu'un qui se moque
choisit n'importe quel prétexte.
Donc...
-Ils ont toujours des prétextes.
-OK ?
-Moi, par exemple, en 6e ou en 5e,
j'ai toujours subi
des moqueries.
Genre, je...
Je stresse beaucoup de mon physique,
comment je me comporte, comment...
J'ai vraiment...
J-J'arrive vraiment...
C'est compliqué
d'être moi-même,
dans un lieu où tu es moqué
pour presque tout ce que tu fais,
trop superficielle,
trop naturelle...
Il faut essayer
de pas croire les moqueries,
mais si on te dit quelque chose
de pas sympa,
tu vas avoir le réflexe
de les croire
et de te remettre
en question,
au lieu de te dire :
"C'est pas à moi
de me remettre en question,
"c'est à toi, et tu peux pas
vraiment changer les gens !"
il faut essayer
de laisser glisser,
mais je travaille encore
dessus.
Laisser glisser les insultes,
les moqueries.
C'est pas parce qu'on t'a insulté,
qu'on t'a mal parlé,
qu'il faut, d'un coup,
s'enfermer aux toilettes
et pleurer comme jamais.
C'est vraiment
des fausses croyances,
en fait.
-Nous sommes en décembre.
Lilou attend
son bulletin de notes.
-Donc,
bulletin de 1er trimestre
de 4e.
Musique rap mélancolique
...
Lilou ?
-Lilou.
-Attention, ici,
les élèves sont notés sur 4,
et pas sur 20.
-Alors...
Le bulletin
de Lilou.
...
que je vous laisse
découvrir.
-Il y a beaucoup de 4, de vert.
C'est bien.
-Beaucoup de 2.
-"Il y a beaucoup de 2".
-Il y a deux 2.
Ca, c'est Lilou qui voit toujours
le verre à moitié vide !
Rire
Mathématiques, tu t'accroches.
-Là, tu vois, les maths,
c'est la petite remarque...
moins positive.
Lilou semble souvent ailleurs.
-J'essaye de suivre, mais...
Mais ça m'ennuie.
-Bonsoir.
-Alors.
Comment ça se passe, Riwan ?
Globalement, quoi.
-Ca va.
-Ca va ?
Tu es à l'aise
dans toutes les matières ?
-Oui. Ca... Ca va.
-Il y a des matières
qui te demandent
du travail ?
-Ben le français,
faut que je travaille l'orthographe.
-Hm ?
-Mais sinon,
ça va.
-Bon, le bulletin, du coup,
on a du très bon,
pas loin
du très, très bon.
Avec un petit 2 qui traîne,
mais avec... Voilà,
des efforts de faits,
des efforts de notés,
et, globalement, on a...
un Riwan qui travaille,
qui fait des efforts.
Faudrait, apparemment,
quand même un petit peu plus
de participation orale.
Qu'est-ce que tu en penses ?
-Euh... Je suis d'accord.
Rires
-Et puis on n'est pas loin du bon,
du très, très bon.
On enchaîne.
Alors.
Mohamed.
Comment ça s'est passé,
ce 1er trimestre ?
-Euh... Je trouve que ça va.
Je trouve que j'ai une bonne classe.
Voilà. J'ai pas plus
de commentaires.
-Globalement, effectivement,
c'est une classe qui est ressentie
comme sympathique,
dynamique, travailleuse.
-Ca, c'est bien !
-C'est vraiment pas mal.
C'est un bon support pour...
-Pour aider.
-Hm-hm.
-Et ça,
c'est le bulletin.
-OK.
-C'est...
un bon bulletin,
mais avec un petit bémol.
-Hm.
-On est tous d'accord
pour dire que Mohamed,
il a des bonnes capacités,
qu'il travaille...
Mais pas partout.
-Hm.
-Et qu'il pourrait certainement
faire un petit peu plus
que ce qu'il fait déjà.
-Oui.
-Ca ne suffit pas.
Il faut que tu en fasses
plus encore.
-Oui. Je me rappelle,
depuis l'école primaire,
c'est ça :
Mohamed peut faire plus,
et qu'il est capable
de faire plus.
C'est toujours... Chaque année...
-Voilà,
il alterne les phases de :
"Je suis à fond dans le travail,
"je fais les choses, etc.",
et puis, par moments,
"Je suis à fond
dans la discussion..."
Il aime bien rigoler,
il est très dynamique,
il a besoin de bouger,
etc., etc.
-Hm.
-C'est ce qu'on te reproche :
le manque de concentration.
-J'ai l'impression
d'avoir plus de difficultés.
Peut-être que la 4e
est plus compliquée.
-Ca vient des cours
ou de toi ?
-Hm, peut-être plus de moi,
je pense.
Oui, plus de moi.
-C'est-à-dire ?
-Peut-être moins de concentration
que les autres années.
Du coup, j'essaie de faire
des efforts, mais des fois,
t'as pas envie, t'as envie
de faire autre chose, etc.
-Les capacités
que tu montres
en EPS, en histoire,
en français, etc.,
faut le généraliser,
et puis te préparer
à une super belle année de 3e.
-Oui.
-C'est notre défi.
Ce qu'on a dit.
-Hm.
-C'est quoi, après la 3e ?
-Ah je sais pas, moi !
Ah non, mais moi, je...
-T'es pas fixé sur un métier.
-Voilà.
C'est ça.
-Super.
C'est pas grave.
Quand ton bulletin t'ouvre
toutes les portes,
tu peux choisir quelles portes
tu vas ouvrir
pour ta formation,
que ce soit en lycée général,
en lycée technologique ou en...
professionnel.
Donc, là, tu t'ouvres les portes,
un petit peu...
Pour aller là
où tu as envie d'aller.
-Hm.
-D'accord ?
OK ?
-Ben merci beaucoup.
-C'est moi qui vous remercie
d'être venus.
Bonne soirée. Au revoir.
-C'est une petite pause
pour se préparer à plus travailler.
En soi, on dirait pas,
comme ça,
mais je vais devoir aller
à l'école pendant 20 ans,
après, je vais devoir faire,
si possible, des grandes écoles,
pour trouver un métier,
puis travailler jusqu'à...
J'ai oublié c'est quel âge,
la retraite.
Je crois qu'il va y avoir
une réforme, pour les 65 ans,
mais... sinon,
après, j'ai oublié.
Bref,
on va dire 60 ans,
et après, enfin,
à ce moment-là,
je pourrai me reposer.
Du coup...
C'est... c'est...
ce petit moment...
cette petite pause,
qui va...
-Tu anticipes la fatigue ?
-Je l'anticipe,
exactement.
On sait jamais.
Rire
Si ça se trouve,
quand je serai vieux,
je me dirai : "J'aurais dû
faire une pause, en 4e."
Musique douce
-C'est pas très, très propre.
Rires
...
-51 !
Ca ressemble pas.
-Quand la mère de Lilou
emmène ses filles visiter Paris,
elle sait leur en mettre
plein la vue.
Cris admiratifs et rires
-Lilou, regarde.
-Ah oui, la tour Eiffel.
-Les Invalides, le dôme doré.
Impressionnant. Notre-Dame.
Tu l'avais vue,
depuis l'incendie ?
-Ils la reconstruisent.
Je l'ai pas vue,
quand elle a brûlé.
En mode : "Ah ben,
je la verrai pas."
-Là, c'est la Sorbonne.
L'université.
-C'est tellement grand.
-Ca vaut le coup de monter.
Exceptionnel.
-C'est où qu'on voit les tombes ?
Ca m'intéresse pas trop, les...
l'architecture et tout, là.
-Lilou est passionnée d'histoire,
et en venant au Panthéon,
elle avait une idée en tête.
-Moi, je veux voir Voltaire.
-Oui, eh bah on va voir
ton ami Voltaire.
-Du moins,
ce qu'il en reste !
-Ou du moins,
ce qu'il en reste.
-C'est où, le truc des tombes ?
-Crypte.
Musique douce
-Ah, c'est là, en fait.
C'est ça, "le crypte".
-Où ils sont, les cadavres ?
-Ah, c'est ça ?
(-Oui.)
C'est le tombeau de Rousseau.
-Ah ! Il est là ?
Rousseau...
Musique mélancolique
...
C'est hyper beau.
Pierre Curie. Marie Curie.
-Ouais, Pierre et Marie Curie.
-C'est quoi, ça ?
-C'est son nom de jeune fille.
-Marie Curie, née...
Elle tente de déchiffrer le nom.
Sklodowska.
...
Ah, Condorcet !
Ca, on l'a vu en histoire-géo.
-C'est un révolutionnaire.
-René Cassin,
Jean Monnet, Simone Veil...
-Là, tu vois ?
-Jean Moulin,
il s'est fait torturer.
-Et André Malraux,
il était ministre de la Culture.
...
-"Hommage de la nation
aux Justes de France."
"Des femmes et des hommes,
de toutes origines et conditions,
"ont sauvé des Juifs
des persécutions antisémites
"et des camps d'extermination."
-C'est vachement important.
-Ouais.
-Parce qu'en France,
il y a tous ces gens anonymes
qui ont fait juste
des petits actes, en fait.
Comme mon grand-père.
Ils étaient dans une ferme
à l'extérieur de Rennes.
Ils ont hébergé
une famille juive
pour les cacher.
Ils n'en parlaient pas
comme une chose héroïque.
C'était tout à fait normal.
-Ils auraient pu risquer leur peau.
-Ah bah c'est clair !
Cette notion de "Justes",
c'est hyper important.
-D'être juste
et d'être tolérant.
Je veux juste voir Voltaire.
-Elle veut juste voir Voltaire.
...
-C'est où
qu'on va voir Voltaire ?
C'est ça, Voltaire ?
Ah oui ! Bien.
Pas mal, hein ?
-Bon, qu'est-ce qu'il a fait, dit,
Voltaire ?
-Il a dit :
"J'ai décidé d'être heureux,
car c'est bon pour la santé."
-Eh bah écoute,
il a l'air d'être en bonne santé.
Il a aussi été avec une femme
des Lumières, Emilie du Châtelet.
Elle, elle a traduit
en deux langues,
en italien et en français,
un texte...
Je sais plus quoi.
-C'était sa femme ?
-Non, en fait, elle,
elle était déjà mariée.
Mais elle a eu
une aventure avec Voltaire.
-On va ressortir.
-"A la gloire
des généraux de la Révolution."
Bonaparte ? Pas ça.
-C'est lui. T'aimes pas Bonaparte.
-Je le déteste.
Je le déteste !
Du plus profond de mon être.
-Pourquoi ?
-C'est un hypocrite !
Je ne veux pas en entendre parler.
-Si Lilou a une dent
contre Napoléon Bonaparte...
-Merci beaucoup. Au revoir.
-C'est qu'elle a
quelques bases historiques.
-Donc, souvenez-vous,
on essaie de comprendre en quoi
les guerres napoléoniennes
et les conquêtes
de la France
vont influencer
les autres pays d'Europe ou pas.
C'est ce qu'on essaie
de comprendre.
La Révolution française
arrive dans ces pays.
Les révolutionnaires, d'abord,
puis les armées napoléoniennes,
en apportant avec eux
la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme.
Comment les populations,
par exemple, en Espagne,
dans la partie est
de l'Europe,
vont réagir ? Riwan ?
Donnez-moi des exemples.
-Dans le texte du document 2...
-Ouais.
-Il est écrit :
"En octobre 1792,
"les soldats français
"occupent Mayence en Rhénanie.
"Les habitants les accueillent
avec joie
"et fondent un club de Jacobins."
-Donc, on danse,
on chante,
on plante des arbres.
Quelle va être l'attitude
des populations de ces pays ?
Pourquoi les choses vont changer ?
Lilou ?
-Les populations réagissent...
Quand la France les libère,
ils vont avoir plus de droits.
-Elles vont être comme ça
tout le temps ?
-Non, uniquement au début.
-Ils se comportent
comme des envahisseurs.
C'est l'inverse.
Oui, Mohammed ?
-Entre le moment
où les Français arrivent
comme des libérateurs
et celui où ils sont vus
comme des envahisseurs,
il se passe combien de temps ?
-Ca dépend.
Quelques mois.
-OK.
-On verra ça un peu plus tard.
-Quoi de mieux
que l'histoire pour se faire
une culture politique ?
-Vous avez le document page 83.
-Lors de l'élection présidentielle,
nos cinq jeunes
ont été marqués par une proposition
très médiatisée :
celle d'obliger les gens
à donner un prénom "français"
à leurs enfants.
-Ca a souvent été comme ça.
-Je comprends pas où est la logique
dans cette phrase.
C'est pas parce que tu donnes
un prénom qui n'est pas français
à un de tes enfants...
Je vois pas en quoi ça exclut
de la société française.
Pour moi, ça veut rien dire.
-On a tous
des prénoms
qui viennent pas forcément...
traditionnellement de la France.
-Riwan, Lilou, Louane, Romain...
-Yanis...
-Khaled, aussi.
-Et puis Tania.
-Paul, Eliott...
-Adam...
-Nassim, Mohamed...
-Enfin, il a raison de dire
que c'est pas un nom traditionnel
français,
mais c'est pas une raison
pour vouloir le changer.
-C'est ça qui fait
la beauté de la France.
-J'ai eu de la chance
d'avoir toujours eu des copains
qui m'ont jamais critiqué pour ça.
-Ils nous apportent de la culture
et plein de choses.
-Ca reflète notre...
D'où l'on vient,
nos origines.
C'est important.
-La France est telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui.
Il ne faut pas la renvoyer
dans un passé.
-Je pensais que la pensée des gens
avait un peu évolué depuis...
Depuis avant, en fait.
-Pour certains,
je comprends que c'est pas normal.
Peut-être qu'ils étaient habitués
à différents types de prénoms,
et que, du jour au lendemain,
quand c'est devenu mixte
avec plein d'autres trucs,
ça a commencé
à déstabiliser les choses
pour ces gens-là.
Du coup, de ce point de vue-là,
je pourrais comprendre.
Propos indistincts
-Ce soir, les esprits sont légers.
Acclamations
-Bravo, Timothée !
-Je vais mettre la musique.
-Pour les 14 ans de Coline,
les garçons mettent la main
à la pâte.
-Tu veux quoi, Timothée ?
-OK.
Brouhaha
-Et ils sont sous le contrôle avisé
de la maîtresse des lieux.
-Les gars, votre beurre,
il va cramer !
Ca a accroché au fond de la truc.
-Non...
Ils rient.
-Pauline, j'ai rajouté
un peu de...
De paprika !
...
-On ne dirait pas...
-Vous êtes épuisants,
je vous jure.
-Mais derrière ses airs de patronne,
Coline cache un mal-être
qu'elle n'avait jamais dévoilé.
-Des fois...
Je ne montre pas
ce que je ressens...
parce que les autres
pourraient me juger,
donc, du coup,
je le montre pas.
*"Mélodie", Elodie Costa
J'aime pas trop
me faire remarquer.
J'ai tendance à m'effacer.
Il y a des choses où je me dis :
"Ouais, non...
"Ne le fais pas."
Ou alors...
"Cache-toi."
J'aimerais être invisible.
Genre...
Mais complètement invisible.
Genre, personne me voit.
Ce serait bien.
12, 13 et 14.
-T'en as mis un peu trop, là.
-J'en ai mis trop pour Timothée.
-Sinon, vous mettez 7 chacun.
-Oh ouais !
-Non.
-Ca fait 14 ans à deux.
-Je veux plein de bougies !
Personnellement,
ça me fait un peu peur
d'être jugée par les gens.
En fait, j'ai peur
de ce qu'ils peuvent penser de moi.
-Quand tu es avec tes amis,
ça a l'air d'aller.
-Je suis différente avec les gens
qu'avec moi-même.
*-Alors on va chanter pour toi !
Et encore une bougie de soufflée
Encore une année passée
Encore une bougie de soufflée
Beaucoup d'amour
Et une santé de fer
Un joyeux anniversaire
-Mais les gens
qui sont proches de moi,
genre mes amis...
Musique contemplative
Si jamais j'enlève
cette espèce de carapace, en fait...
Bah, je sais pas
ce qu'ils penseront de moi.
Du coup, je le fais pas.
-T'as peur qu'ils t'aiment moins ?
-Ouais.
-Mais les amis...
C'est fait pour t'aimer,
aimer ce que tu es.
-Ouais, mais il y a des fois
où c'est pas moi.
-Mais du coup, ils t'aiment toi
ou ils aiment la fausse Coline ?
A ton avis ?
-Peut-être les deux.
Parce qu'il y a des moments
où j'arrive à être moi,
mais c'est pas
la majorité du temps.
Ils applaudissent en rythme.
Rires de joie
-Si tu étais 100 % toi-même
avec eux,
tu ferais le tri
entre les amis ?
-Ouais, mais non,
j'ai pas envie.
...
-1, 2, 3 !
Applaudissements
-Salut, Coco.
-Ouais !
-Bonne soirée.
-Bonne soirée !
-Le moi de ma chambre,
il est différent du moi
à l'extérieur de la maison.
Musique douce
Il y a des choses
que je laisse dans ma chambre,
que j'essaie de cacher.
C'est pas tellement
que j'assume pas,
mais...
En fait,
j'ai toujours eu, je pense...
Deux personnalités
un petit peu différentes.
J'ai appris à...
A garder ma personnalité à moi
pour moi et à montrer
ce que je voulais
montrer aux autres.
...
-Il y en a avec qui
tu enlèves ce visage ?
...
-Non.
Euh...
J'écoute du Adele, Pink
Doja Cat, Billie Eilish,
mais principalement Taylor Swift.
Je les ai tous, en fait.
Du coup, mon préféré,
c'est celui-là, c'est "Folklore".
Il est un peu abîmé,
je l'utilise souvent.
Je l'adore tellement,
je l'écoute tout le temps.
En ce moment,
c'est 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
9.
Elle, "This Is Me Trying".
Ca me remonte vraiment le moral,
d'écouter cette chanson-là.
C'est beaucoup
de paroles, à un moment,
qui me marquent énormément.
En fait, je sais pas,
ça me fait penser à moi.
"This Is Me Trying", Taylor Swift
C'est un peu...
"Ils m'ont dit que, en fait,
tout venait de moi, en fait,
"et que j'ai commencé à perdre
tout mon potentiel
"parce qu'on me reprochait
des choses
"et que je me suis mise
"à faire tout pour les gens
et que tout mon potentiel
"s'est mis à se perdre."
En fait, ça parle du fait
qu'on a du mal
à faire confiance aux gens,
et quand on est un peu brisé,
on essaie
d'essayer de continuer à essayer,
en fait.
Au moins, on essaie
et on essaie de faire au mieux.
Pour moi, c'est vraiment une musique
qui me représente
d'une certaine manière,
parce que tous les jours, j'essaie.
-Pour Mohamed...
-Du coup,
on fait le truc de blind test.
-...la musique
est un peu moins introspective.
-Je commence là,
comme ça, gratuit.
J'ai envie de trouver
des musiques compliquées.
Tu vas reconnaître.
Retourne-toi.
*Musique douce
-"MD", Niska et Tiakola.
-OK.
Jamais tu trouves ça.
*Musique calme
-"Maman ne le sait pas",
Ninho et Niska.
-Bien joué.
*-Dans la ville
J'revends le cannabis
Maman ne le sait pas
J'recompte mes potes
Tout près des haramistes
Le canon d'vant la glace
A moi !
*-J'arrive dans 10 minutes
La sportive garée
-Je crois pas que je connaisse.
-Si, tu l'as déjà écouté.
Le refrain, tu vas reconnaître.
-Gazo ? L'autre, je crois pas
que je le connais.
-C'est Timal.
-Le titre,
je l'ai
sur le bout de la langue.
*-C'est pas du narguilé
-J'ai oublié le titre.
-"Filtré".
-Faut pas montrer ça.
-On le met pas.
-On va pas montrer le clip.
-Nos parents,
ils vont voir ce qu'on regarde.
-On en fait un autre.
-On en met un un peu plus facile.
Musique tonique
-Le temps passe.
Nous arrivons
au dernier trimestre
de l'année, et Riwan
a quelques lauriers à récolter.
*-C'est avec un immense plaisir
que je vous souhaite à tous
la bienvenue au collège
pour les remises des prix
aux gagnants du concours
Arela 2022.
Le sujet
du concours 2022
était
"Dieux et hommes :
quand les dieux s'en mêlent".
550 inscrits
dans l'académie de Rennes.
Bravo
aux 55 lauréats.
*-C'est une élève
de quatrième
qui a donc le premier prix.
Applaudissements
...
Alors, une enceinte connectée.
Félicitations !
Le deuxième est un élève...
...
13e,
Riwan !
...
Elève de Claire Rouger-Hurquin,
il pourra peaufiner sa culture
avec "Astérix chez les Pictes".
...
Donc félicitations
à tous ces lauréats,
à tous les professeurs
qui ont su mener leurs élèves
à leur réussite.
-Je vous remercie d'être venus.
-De rien.
Je voulais venir.
Il reçoit un prix,
c'est pas tous les jours,
non plus.
-Voilà. C'est un fan de manga ?
-Manga, BD,
ça passe sous la main,
je lis.
-C'est quoi le livre qu'elle a eu,
aussi, là ?
-Les "Percy Jackson".
-Les "Percy Jackson", il les a tous.
Est-ce que je les ai tous pris ?
Pour les "Percy Jackson",
c'est bon.
on peut dire que ça,
j'ai tout lu.
C'est du même auteur.
Dans celui-là, on retrouve
Percy Jackson, qui est grec,
qui arrive dans un clan romain.
J'adore la lecture.
-Vous avez vu les adaptations
aussi ?
-Au cinéma ? Oui, les films,
ils résument trop...
-Le livre.
-Les livres.
-Trop condensé pour vous ?
Pour les connaisseurs.
Voilà une perspective !
Vous allez passer au lycée
Chateaubriand dans 2 ans,
vous allez faire l'option
cinéma audiovisuel
et dans quelques années,
vous nous remontez
les "Percy Jackson"
comme vous voulez.
-Voilà, c'est bien.
-Eh bien bravo,
félicitations à Riwan.
Au revoir.
-Au revoir.
-Ben e gwelet.
-Ben e gwelet, et félicitations.
Hein ? 13e, c'est bien.
Voilà, souris.
On est fiers de vous.
Bravo !
...
Musique tonique
-Justement, Chateaubriand.
C'est le lycée
tout près du collège
et très prisé
des bons élèves.
-Eh non !
...
-La professeure a dit
qu'on a les capacités
d'aller chercher
du travail en plus
pour combler nos manques,
pour se préparer au lycée, quoi.
-Au collège,
on nous apprend pas à bosser.
-Attention !
Le lycée Chateaubriand,
c'est là que s'imaginent Maël
et ses copains.
...
-Vous allez à Chateau ?
-OUAIS.
-Ils demandent un niveau de ouf.
Ma soeur,
elle a des potes qui ont décroché
en seconde, trop haut niveau.
-Des sacrées attentes.
-Après, ils font l'élite
pour la prépa.
-Il y a aussi
cinéma audiovisuel.
-Moi, de toute façon,
je vais prendre euro, c'est sûr.
-Je me demande
si je ferais pas russe.
Histoire-géographie,
géopolitique et sciences politiques.
-En vrai, ça a l'air trop bien.
-Il faut prendre
le plus d'options possibles.
-Il faut pas en prendre trop.
Mon frère en avait 3,
il finissait tous les jours
à 18h, sauf le vendredi.
-Il faut prendre des options
pour s'habituer à bosser,
dans tous les cas, faut...
Pour après, pour Parcoursup.
Là, il pleut.
Vous voulez pas, on rentre ?
Il pleut.
...
-Pour la mère de Mohamed,
avant le lycée,
il y a déjà la troisième,
et son fameux stage en entreprise.
-On est en train de chercher.
On va mettre
les métiers de l'informatique.
...
-Elle veut lancer les recherches
dès maintenant.
...
-"10 métiers de l'informatique
qui recrutent."
Tu peux cliquer.
-"Technicien
d'assistance informatique".
"Intégrateur Web
ou développeur Web".
"Chargé de CRM",
"Ingénieur de cybersécurité",
"Data analyst".
OK, donc dans les métiers
que je vois,
il y a "technicien
pour ordinateurs", en gros.
-Hm hm.
-"Développeur informatique",
"développeur mobile",
pour des applications.
"Ingénieur... dans le Web".
Je sais pas exactement ce que c'est.
Bah voilà, quoi.
Je suis pas sûr que des métiers
dans l'informatique
prennent des stages.
Peut-être. Je sais pas.
-Si, si.
Voilà !
-Je sais pas...
Je trouve que c'est...
Pas que c'est une mauvaise idée,
mais...
-Bah réfléchis
sur ce que tu veux faire.
-Je sais, mais voilà, quoi.
-T'as encore...
-J'ai le temps, je sais.
-T'as quelques...
Normalement,
c'est au mois de janvier, le stage.
C'est dans le calendrier.
-Je sais plus quand c'est.
Moi, je veux bien faire,
au moins pour essayer,
mais ça m'emballe pas tant que ça
non plus.
-Moi, ça m'inquiète,
parce que voilà, il faut...
Il faut trouver quelque chose,
pour le stage.
-Je peux poser une question ?
D'où t'es venue l'idée
que je fasse un métier
dans l'informatique ?
-Euh...
-La 1re fois que tu m'as dit ça,
je m'y attendais pas du tout.
-Parce que tu sais pas encore
quoi faire.
Je me dis que tu peux tenter ça
et tu verras.
-OK.
Musique douce
-L'année scolaire est terminée.
Lilou fait le bilan.
Ses problèmes
ne se sont pas arrangés.
La 4e a été rude,
alors elle a pris une décision.
-L'année prochaine,
je vais changer de collège.
Je quitte Les Gayeulles
et je vais dans le collège privé
juste derrière,
l'Assomption.
C'est une décision que j'ai prise.
J'espère me faire
de nouveaux amis,
pouvoir être dans une classe
sans me sentir jugée constamment,
en fait.
Cette année,
ça a été très compliqué.
Je me suis pas sentie à ma place
dans l'établissement.
Le problème,
je pense qu'il vient aussi de moi.
Et en fait... On peut pas...
On peut pas changer non plus
comment les élèves de la classe
réagissent,
comment... comment...
comment l'établissement
devrait être géré.
Je peux pas changer ça, en fait.
Musique émouvante
J'ai énormément
de mauvais souvenirs, aux Gayeulles.
Je me sentais pas bien,
dans la classe.
C'est pour ça
que j'ai envie de reprendre
un peu à zéro,
d'une certaine manière.
Je suis contente d'aller de l'avant,
d'aller complètement
dans un autre environnement.
Je serai un peu triste,
quand même, de le quitter,
mais je pense
que c'est pour le mieux.
Enfin, j'espère.
J'espère que c'est pour le mieux,
voilà.
Musique planante
...
-Au rayon des changements radicaux,
Coline a aussi quelque chose
à annoncer.
...
-Je m'en vais.
Je pars en Angleterre pendant un an.
...
-Ses parents ont décidé de partir
en famille à Manchester,
avec des objectifs
pour les enfants :
apprendre à s'adapter
et à parler anglais
en immersion.
...
-Là, il y a plus rien.
Là, je vais laisser juste ça,
...
la lampe,
et le tabouret.
Et c'est tout.
...
-Et lui, il reste pas ?
-Non, je l'emmène.
...
Je vais être dans une école anglaise
avec des Anglais.
Au début, ça va être un peu galère,
parce que je parle pas anglais
couramment.
...
Je vais comprendre un mot sur 10.
J'ai fini ma chambre !
Je sais pas où je mets les trucs.
-T'emmènes Raoul ?
-Bah oui.
Quelqu'un sonne à la porte.
Amy arrive.
Coucou !
Vous pouvez rentrer.
-Amy, on t'attend.
Il y a le camion à remplir.
On s'est dit que tu pouvais venir...
-Ca va le faire !
Rires
-Il faut vider tous les placards
de la cuisine.
Musique rock
-Il faut mettre du journal.
Sinon, ils vont se casser.
...
Tu peux faire ça, aussi. Celui-là.
-Tes amis vont te manquer, ou pas ?
-Ils vont me manquer
mais c'est pas grave,
c'est comme ça.
C'est sûr que je vais me sentir
seule à un moment.
-T'auras pas envie
de les avoir avec toi ?
-Je vais les appeler.
C'est très bien.
Voilà, on a emballé notre saladier.
Là, si on le fait tomber...
-Bah vas-y, on essaye.
Ca va pas ?
-Ca va rentrer.
-Comment il va respirer, là ?
-Il y a pas besoin de respirer.
Oh !
Eh ben, ça va aller là.
Je voulais l'avoir avec moi devant,
pour le voyage.
-Il y a les gros cartons.
-Je pars dans une demi-heure.
Je réalise même pas
que je vais partir
et que je serai pas là
pendant un an.
-Si c'est lourd, dites-le.
Je viens les chercher.
Ca rentre plutôt bien.
-Je vais nous trouver une adresse
de sushis, à Ouistreham.
-3, 2, 1, moi d'abord.
-Je sais, toi d'abord !
Je suis pas folle.
-Allez, c'est parti.
Musique dynamique
...
En route, Coline.
A Manchester !
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA